where's the nearest coffee shop where
can I get cheap gas nearby what time is
the next bus if your Android app knows
the user's location and context it can
offer the most relevant help and
information in the moment take the
location and context course built by
Udacity and Google to learn how to
update your Android app to detect the
user's location and activity to offer
the best possible experience no matter
where the user is no matter what they're
doing learn how to use the fused
location provider to get the current
location delve into activity recognition
to tailor your app to what the user is
doing learn how location services work
alongside geofences to allow you to
build apps that could be used for
augmented reality get started now your
users are waiting for more information
visit udacity.com/google